[MUSIC PLAYING]
WOLFF DOBSON: Hi, everybody.
I'm Wolff Dobson,
and I apparently
can't walk up stairs.
No.
I'm Wolff Dobson.
I'd like to talk to you
today about the frontiers
of TensorFlow.
So this talk's got three parts.
We're going to talk
about the latest
developments in TensorFlow.
We're going to talk about
Cloud TPUs and TPU pods.
And finally, Zak's going to
tell us about the TensorFlow
research cloud.
OK.
So TensorFlow-- it's machine
learning for everyone.
We like to say that it
is fast, it is flexible,
and it is production ready.
When we say "production
ready," what we mean
is the code that you mess
around with on your laptop,
that you try out on
your local machine--
it's the same code that you push
out to run on giant clusters.
It's all the same
thing, all the way
down-- no rewriting
in a new language
after you figured it out.
So TensorFlow is
this language that
allows you to write
computational graphs
and use these computational
graphs to do, usually,
machine learning and
often deep learning.
So here's an example of a
basic deep learning graph.
Here we have a picture
of a cat or a dog
that we feed in as pixels
into the convolutional layer
at the bottom.
And then it convolves
all the way down
to give us a prediction
of some kind.
Either it's a cat,
or it's a dog.
Convolutional errors
are one kind of thing.
This is another kind of thing.
This is a collection
of connected layers
where we have each node
on each layer connects
to every other node
on the next layer.
The arrows between
those are all weights.
Those weights are-- we live
to call them parameters.
And they get changed over time.
This is a very deep network
where this is inception V3.
Inception V3 has
about 17 layers,
depending on how you count.
And it has about 25
million parameters.
So it can take a while to train.
And so what do you do when
you're writing TensorFlow?
You're writing probably
Python, and you're going
to knock out some Python there.
And it's going to generate
this graph for you.
And then that graph, you're
going to execute later.
And you're going can
execute it in two ways.
One, you're going to
be doing training,
which means that you're going to
be showing examples and, based
on the results you get,
modifying those parameters.
And then you can run it
again later on new data.
We call that inference.
And we're hoping to get some
kind of statistical insight out
of all the data that we
have onto this new data.
TensorFlow runs on all
kinds of platforms--
CPU, GPU.
Obviously, we're going
to talk about TPUs later.
They're pretty neat.
And also on mobile,
iOS and Android.
And actually, also
on Raspberry Pi.
Raspberry Pi is fun.
You can actually compile all
of TensorFlow on Raspberry Pi.
And we support all
kinds of languages.
Google supports Python,
C++, Java, and Go.
These others are all
community projects.
We're really excited about
the community picking these
up and using our low-level C
bindings to create new language
wrappers.
And TensorFlow comes with a lot
of different kinds of tools.
This tool is TensorBoard.
TensorBoard is sort of like
x-ray for your training
process.
It allows you to look
inside your training
and see what's actually
going on inside your graph,
let's you inspect your graph.
And in this case, we're even
showing off an embedding.
That's MNIST, for those
of you who recognize it.
It's handwriting data.
And you can see we're kind of
grouping all the fives as gray
and all the nines as red.
It's really neat to be
able to look and see
what's actually going on.
And once you've got
this all trained up
and you want to push
it into production,
we have TensorFlow Serving.
TensorFlow Serving is a
separate open source project,
also developed by Google,
that lets you kind of manage
the process of serving
a model in production.
And unless you do things
like serve multiple models
in production, use it with
some kind of container engine,
like Kubernetes, it
allows you to manage
the process of setting up one
of these big services that
will allow you to do
insight for your customers.
There's a great talk about this.
I encourage you.
Noah Fidel is going to be
speaking about it on Friday.
So inside Google,
TensorFlow is very popular.
This is a graph of
directories inside Google
with model description files
in it, which is to say,
this is like a little
piece of machine
learning that we have inside
our main Google repository.
And you can see TensorFlow
launched in Q3 2014,
internally.
We actually had another
system before this.
It was called DistBelief.
DistBelief was great.
It wasn't quite flexible enough
for the kinds of projects
that we wanted to do.
And you can see after we
launched TensorFlow internally,
there was this kind
of explosion of trying
to apply ML to every kind
of problem at Google--
Search, Gmail, Translate, Maps--
all kinds of stuff.
And in November 2015, we
launched TensorFlow in public.
It quickly became one
of the most popular--
actually, the most popular--
machine learning GitHub
project.
And when we say "most popular,"
we mean really most popular.
This is a graph of all
of our stars over time.
We're really happy
about community.
And speaking of community,
since November 2015,
we've had 17,000 commits
in public, many of those
from external contributors.
We have almost 500
non-Googlers contributors
And for TensorFlow version
1.0, which we cut in February.
And we've actually had some very
significant external commits.
One that comes to mind is
the Windows GPU support
was actually external.
And it was committed in,
and we absolutely loved it.
And if you hunt
around on GitHub,
you'll find thousands
of other repositories
that have TensorFlow
in the title.
And along with that
comes blogs and books
and all kinds of other
materials that, again,
the community is
putting together.
And we're so happy
that they are.
We also take supporting
TensorFlow seriously.
One of the great things about
working on the TensorFlow team
is our engineering team
actually takes rotations
through Stack Overflow
and also issues and PRs.
So we've had over 5,000 Stack
Overflow questions answered
and, again, about 5,000
GitHub issues filed
and triaged in some useful way.
And we have a lot of activity.
We're getting almost
160 new issues a week.
So where are we today?
Last night-- actually,
yesterday afternoon--
we branched TensorFlow 1.2.
There's a lot of new
stuff in Tensor 1.2
around supporting TPUs.
Brennan is going
to talk about that.
But something that's
come into TensorFlow
recently is XLS, which
is TensorFlow's compiler
for Accelerated Linear Algebra--
XLA.
And basic idea is
TensorFlow graphs go in,
and optimized assembly
comes out-- machine code
that will actually run.
It's not like an optimized
version of the graph.
It's like-- it is optimized
version of the graph,
but it's actually
running in machine code.
Super important to
support custom hardware.
And again, we'll talk more
about this with the TPU section.
TensorFlow is a distributed
execution engine
that runs on top of all these
other kernels for iOS, Android,
GPUs, CPUs-- all
that kind of stuff.
On top of that, we have
the Python frontend,
which is how you program it.
We have a C++ frontend as well
and all these other languages.
Recently in TensorFlow,
we've added Layers API.
And Layers API gives you
sort of big building blocks
that are the right shape for
you to do basic machine learning
tasks in the kinds of ways we've
done-- convolutional layers,
fully connected layers--
all that kind of thing.
And on top of that, we have
both Keras and Estimators.
Keras is an API that actually
didn't originate at Google.
But we liked it so much, it's
actually in contrib right now.
Keras is a high-level API that
gives you even sort of easier
powerful ways to fit
all these different--
all your graphs together.
And it's actually built on
top of our Layers API as well.
And then we also
have Estimators.
And Estimators are
a way to package up
an abstract away sort of the
concepts of machine learning.
It has fit and evaluate and
all the rest of that stuff.
Again, Estimators are really
important for parallelization.
And with Estimators, we've even
come with canned Estimators
that are going to
help you just--
if you just have some data and
you want to do a simple linear
regression or linear classifier
or a bunch of fully connected
layers--
whatever it is that
you want, we might
be able to give you a
canned estimator that
allows you to do no
graph construction
and just drop your data and go.
The effect of all
these high-level APIs,
like Keras and
canned Estimators--
one of the things you're going
to see is code gets smaller.
But beyond that, like I said,
a big thing about Estimators
is they help you parallelize
your computation.
And we're going to talk
about that more, because TPUs
are super parallel.
Speaking of performance,
let's talk about performance.
About a week and a half ago, we
released a bunch of benchmarks.
They're actually
on TensorFlow.org.
There's a link down there.
This is one of the
graphs on that page--
NVIDIA DGX-1 running
on synthetic data
on one, two, four,
or eight GPUs.
And there's lot of
raw throughput there.
You can see a whole bunch
of images per second.
Images per second--
super important.
Another thing that's really
important in machine learning
is that you get good scale-up.
What that means is
if I add another GPU,
do I get another GPU's worth
of performance out of that?
So in this graph, if you
go from four to eight GPUs,
do you actually see
double the performance?
It's a little bit hard
to read on this graph,
so we made it a
little bit easier.
An ideal scaling line
on this graph-- and this
is GPUs on one access and
speed-up on the other.
And you'd want, with one
GPU, you have 1x speed up.
And eight GPUs, you
have 8x speed up.
And you want a straight
line all the way down there.
And on our test data, which
are common models in machine
learning-- inception,
resonate 50--
you can see we're
getting pretty close.
On the left is synthetic data.
Synthetic data is
when you're kind
of holding your inputs
more or less constant.
And you're just putting
the engine on cinder blocks
and just revving the engine
as fast as you possibly can.
At Google, we think it's
kind of important to try it
with real data as well.
So on the right, we
have the same test
except with real data.
And you can see it's
not quite as ideal.
It's never going to be
ideal, because there's
going to be overhead for doing
the parallel computation.
But we're getting pretty close.
And if you want to scale
out to lots of GPUs,
we have benchmarks
for that as well.
This goes out to 64 GPUs, this
time on K80s in the cloud.
Again, you're looking for that--
from 32 to 64, are you
getting double the throughput?
But don't take my word for it.
Try it yourself.
Not only did we release the page
that has all these benchmarks
and graphs on it, we
also released the code.
So you can download it and run
it yourself on your own setup.
And we have benchmarks on
NVIDIA DGX-1, Google Compute
Engine, Amazon EC2.
But please, try it on your own
setup and tell us how it goes.
Also, that code is
tuned for speed.
And so it's a good place to look
that if you're having issues
with scale up, you can
take a look at our stuff
and see how we did it and
see if that can help you.
But 64 GPUs is a lot.
But there's more than 64 GPUs.
And with very large
models, you're
going to need a lot more
computation to train them.
And that kind of computation
is more powerful chips,
faster communication
among accelerators,
faster memory, and a fully
optimized software stack.
So to tell you about
that-- to tell you
about TPUs, which are
all of those things,
I'm going to hand it off to Zak.
ZAK STONE: Thanks, Wolff.
I'm super excited about TPUs.
And I'd like to share the story
of their development with you
today.
Some of you may remember
this image here.
This is an image of
Google's first generation
TPU, which Sundar revealed
at Google I/O last year.
Google actually considered
building custom ASICs as early
as 2006.
But the situation got
more urgent in 2013
when one of our star engineers
realized if all Android
users spoke to their phones
for just three minutes a day,
that might force
Google to double
its number of data centers.
So that drove this crash project
to develop our first TPU,
which, in just 15 months
of building and deploying
these in the data
centers, brought us
to some pretty significant
performance gains
across Search Ranking, Google
Photos, Street View, Google
Translate, and a variety of
our other large scale machine
learning applications.
In fact, compared to
contemporary CPUs and TPUs,
this first generation
TPU was 15 to 30x
faster on these
internal workloads
while being 30 to 80x
more power-efficient.
But there was an important
limitation, namely
that this first generation TPU
was designed for inference, not
training.
As Wolff mentioned
earlier, training
is this enormously
complicated process
of setting all those weights
in these giant machine learning
models.
And then inference is the
process of running the models.
And so while the first
generation TPU was fantastic
for running models that
had already been trained,
Google still needed to
use other hardware--
huge clusters of CPUs or GPUs--
to train these models.
That inspired the development
of our second generation
TPU, which is what Sundar
announced yesterday.
This device delivers
up to 180 teraflops
of floating-point performance
and contains 64 gigabytes
of ultra-high-bandwidth memory.
The most important thing about
this new second generation TPU
is that it's designed
to support both training
and inference on one platform.
And that turns out to
be really convenient,
because it allows you
to develop your model
and then run it in
exactly the same way.
You don't have this
barrier of friction
of having to
quantize the weights
or figure out how to deploy
it on a separate platform.
But for some of
Google's largest scale
machine learning problems, even
180 teraflops isn't enough.
And so from the beginning,
the second generation TPUs
were designed to be
connected together
with an ultra fast
custom network.
We call these collections
of TPUs, pods.
And the TPU pods
that you see here
contain 64 of these new
second generation TPUs.
If you add all that up, that
gives you up to 11.5 petaflops
of machine learning
acceleration that you
can apply to a single machine
learning training problem,
or you can split up to support
many different training
problems in parallel.
This whole system has
four terabytes of memory.
And the TPUs are connected in
a toroidal mesh network which
facilitates the ultra fast,
ultra dense communication
that you need, especially to
solve these machine learning
training problems.
We're already seeing
interesting results
on some of the important
internal workloads
that matter to us.
For example, on one of our
new large-scale neural machine
translation models,
it used to take us
24 hours to train this model
on 32 of the best commercially
available GPUs.
Now in just six hours, we can
train to the same accuracy
on 1/8 of a TPU pod.
These new devices-- these
second generation TPUs--
we're thrilled to
announce are coming
to Google Cloud as cloud TPUs.
Our goal is for Google
Cloud to be the best
cloud for machine learning.
So we offer customers the
choice of the best hardware
that you can find
anywhere, whether that's
Skylake CPUs, NVIDIA's GPUs.
We're planning to
introduce Volta and now
this new member of the
family, clouds TPUs,
so customers can build the
best machine learning systems
for their specific workloads.
To tell you a little bit more
about how cloud TPUs are going
to integrate with
TensorFlow, I'd
like to hand it off to Brennan.
BRENNAN SAETA: Thank you, Zak.
Today, I want to talk
to you about cloud TPUs.
Now as we've
designed cloud TPUs,
we wanted to ensure that
it would meet your needs,
whether you are a
researcher or whether you're
designing a high-skill,
high-performance machine
learning product.
And so for
researchers, we wanted
to ensure that it was
interactive and low-level.
You can play around with
your models and debug them.
And for high-performance,
high-scale platforms
and products, we
wanted to ensure
that it would integrate with the
rest of Google Cloud Platform.
But I think that instead of
me just telling you about it,
it's more exciting
if I show you.
Now before I show you, I want
to say an important caveat.
As we bring TPUs
to Google Cloud,
there's a lot of moving pieces.
And so some of those pieces are
still under active development.
So things may change.
That said, let's get started.
The simplest model
that I think I can show
you is alpha times x plus y.
So alpha is the constant 2.
x is a vector, or we call
it tensor, of three 1's.
y is also three 1's.
And we hope to, at the
end of this computation,
get three 3's.
In order to use
Google Cloud TPUs,
you've got to first create one.
When you create one,
this is your cloud TPU.
And so in order to
access it, however,
you need to access it via
Google Compute Engine.
So we first create a virtual
machine in Google's Compute
Engine product.
And we're going to
name it Demo VM.
Additionally, we're
going to create a TPU.
And we're going to
call that Demo TPU.
If we then log in
to our demo VM,
this is what we could see
after we install TensorFlow.
So we're going to run the
Python interactive interpreter.
And we're going to import
TensorFlow just like normal.
After that, we're going to
connect to our cloud TPU
using GRPC, Google's open
source RPC framework.
After that, you use TensorFlow
just like you normally would,
whether on a CPU or a GPU.
The only difference,
however, is that you
define your computations that
you want to run on the TPU
in this with TF.deviceblock.
In doing so, you tell TensorFlow
to run the computation
on the TPU.
After that, you can
just run it, again,
just like normal TensorFlow.
And it just works.
It's very exciting.
So to review what
just happened, we
logged in to our Google
Compute Engine VM.
We ran our TensorFlow and our
Python interactive interpreter.
We connected to the cloud
TPU and ran our computation
on the cloud TPU and
fetched the results back
into our Google
Compute Engine VM.
But this one VM
and one cloud TPU
is really only the beginning.
We've designed cloud
TPUs to integrate
with all the rest
of the hardware
and compute platforms available
in Google Cloud Platform.
So if you have a model that
part of the model runs really,
really well on brand new
GPUs and part of your model
runs really, really
well on cloud TPUs,
you can create your own
esoteric heterogeneous cluster
and place your model so that the
right parts of the computation
run on the right compute nodes.
But one thing we've
learned at Google
is that as you
push the boundaries
of computational power--
as you push extreme scale,
you need to optimize the
entire system from end to end.
And what I mean is, I mean you
need to take into account not
just the amount
of disks that you
use to feed your data quickly
into these accelerator pods
and not just the
network that connects
all of these distributed
machines together,
but you also need a highly
tuned software platform.
And to tell you
about that, I'd like
to tell you about some of
the latest changes that
are happening that are still
under active development
in Core TensorFlow.
Now previously in
the presentation,
we had a picture of the
Core TensorFlow platform.
And I've redrawn that,
adding a few extra boxes.
And I'm going to talk to you
today about XLA, Estimators,
and Datasets.
Let's start with closest
to the bare metal.
Let's talk about XLA.
TensorFlow is designed to go
from research to production.
And production means not just
servers in a data center,
but it means going all
the way from phones
to these exotic hardware
compute devices like TPUs.
And in order to run
efficiently and to get
the extreme performance, you
need a highly-tuned software
stack.
As it turns out, in order
to get optimized code,
you need to bring
your own compiler.
XLA is TensorFlow's compiler.
XLA stands for Accelerated
Linear Algebra.
And what it does--
when you use
TensorFlow, you define
your computational graph.
And XLA will take a
subset of that graph,
or maybe even the whole graph.
It will run a huge number of
optimization passes over it.
And it will output
exactly the machine binary
to run on the hardware
that you're targeting.
In this example, we're taking
the inception algorithm
that does extreme performance
on image recognition.
And XLA will take a
subset of that graph.
And it will reorder
the computations
and output the
assembly in binary form
to run efficiently
on CPUs or GPUs.
But XLA was designed for the
explosion in exotic hardware
that we see in machine learning.
XLA has a pluggable backend
so that you can target
your own hardware elements.
TPUs are just a custom
backend for XLA.
And in doing so,
we take advantage
of all the optimizations
that we do for CPUs and GPUs,
and we're able to run
them also on TPUs.
But XLA runs sort of
underneath the hood.
And so it's sometimes
a little hard to see.
So if you'd like to
see XLA in action,
you can turn on Tracing
when you run your TensorFlow
computation.
And if you print out the
trace information that's
stored in that Run
Metadata object,
you might see
something like this.
In one of the node stats, so we
see this funny underscore XLA
Launch operation.
If you're not using
XLA, the node stats
will be your
TensorFlow graph nodes.
But what happens when you
use XLA is the XLA compiler
generates that optimized binary.
And the XLA Launch operation
is the time spent actually
running that binary on
your compute devices.
But one thing that's
interesting is the node
names don't
correspond necessarily
with your TensorFlow graph.
And the reason for that is
that XLA performs whole program
optimization.
If you've ever used
an optimizing compiler
and looked at the assembly
that's output afterwards,
you'll notice that it
doesn't necessarily
match up with your
statements that you write in,
for example, C.
That's because the
optimizing compiler
is doing a number of
tricks underneath the hood
to get optimal
machine performance.
And XLA is doing that
not just at the function
or the operation level, but
it's scheduling whole programs
to run efficiently.
So we've talked
about XLA or how you
run on these new
hardware platforms
all the way across the
range of devices we support.
But I now want to talk
about how you actually
write your algorithms
so that they can
run across all these platforms.
And for that, we
have Estimators.
Now this code
snippet I'm showing
you is copy pasted directly
from our source repository
that it runs on CPUs and use.
And I'm going to show you how
we can modify it to run on TPUs.
When you use Estimators,
you define your machine
learning algorithm
using a model function.
And this is the
model definition for
a simple convolutional
neural network
to recognize
hand-written digits.
This is the MNIST data set, for
those of you who are familiar.
I want to draw your attention
to the final three lines.
And in order to see them
a little bit better,
we've made them a
little bit bigger.
Normally when you train your
machine learning algorithm,
you use a gradient descent
optimizer or similar
to optimize the weights.
This is the training step
of your machine learning
algorithm.
In order to get
it to run on TPUs,
you just wrap your
gradient descent optimizer
with a TPU
cross-shard optimizer.
TPUs have a number of
parallel compute elements
that all work together.
And in order to aggregate
the learned weights,
you need to use this
cross-shard optimizer to relearn
the entire algorithm.
That is the only
change required when
you're using Estimators to
run on CPUs, GPUs, and TPUs
for this example.
Now how do you actually run it?
You've got to define
your main function.
And using Estimators,
it's very simple.
Normally, you just
define your Estimator
based on your model
function, and you call Train.
And to get us to work on TPUs,
you just use a TPU Estimator
and use a TPU run config.
That's it.
That is all the changes
required for this model
to work on CPUs, GPUs, and TPUs.
Some more complicated models
may require additional code
changes.
But the TensorFlow
team is constantly
working to reduce the amount
of code changes required
as you go all the way
to production on all
these different platforms.
If you'd like to hear more
about these high-level APIs,
I encourage you to
check out the talk
in the next hour
about TensorFlow
with the high-level APIs.
So we've talked about how to
define your machine learning
algorithms, and we've
talked about how they
execute on hardware devices.
But we're missing one key thing.
The machine learning
triad that has resulted
in this explosion
of progress has been
fueled by three components--
high-performance
computation, advances
in algorithms, and
also, input data.
Without input data, all the
fancy acceleration you want
is not going to generate any
more than random numbers.
Clouds are designed to integrate
with the rest of Google Cloud
Platform to make it easy to load
data in a high-performance way.
You can load data from
your persistent disk
or your ephemeral local SSD
on Google Compute Engine.
But you can also
stream data in directly
from Google Cloud Storage
into your cloud TPUs.
And for those of you doing
advanced reinforcement learning
algorithms or other
sorts of things,
you can run simulators
on Google Compute Engine
and integrate that with
your machine learning model
running on your cloud TPUs.
But as it turns
out, we at Google,
we've been deploying these
high-performance accelerators--
CPUs and GPUs-- for a while.
And we've found
that when you really
put them into production,
you find new bottlenecks.
And I think this is best
explained with an example.
If you've optimized
your software platform,
you'll often use
pipelining techniques
to overlap computation.
And that's what we've done here.
For this image model, we
run some input processing
on the CPU for the
next training step
while our accelerator
is running the model
and learning on the
current training step.
But if you all the sudden just
take this and port this over
to an accelerator
that's 10 times faster,
your training step
time is not going
to decrease anywhere
close to what you'd hope.
To help you feed data in in a
flexible but high-performance
manner, we're
introducing a new API
in TensorFlow 1.2
called Datasets.
TensorFlow 1.2, the
first release candidate,
is coming out as we speak.
And we encourage you all
to try out these new APIs,
kick the tires.
Although they're still
a work in progress,
we think they're very exciting.
And I'd like to show you
a little bit about what
this Dataset API looks like.
Here is a code snippet
where we load a set of data
from a TF record file on disk.
We then repeat that data set
as we train our algorithm.
We perform some parsing
and distortions to this,
using the Parser function.
But we can do this in parallel
using the Parallel Num Threads,
so we do a parallel map.
Finally, we batch this
up into training bunches
that we then feed
to our accelerator.
This new Datasets API borrows
from functional programming
and other advanced
concepts to make
it easy to define
high-performance input
pipelines that run well.
We've talked about now XLA,
Estimators, and Datasets.
And these are just some
of the new changes that
are coming in
TensorFlow 1.2 that help
make these high-performance
accelerators, be they CPUs
or GPUs or TPUs, really sing.
And on top of this
base of awesome compute
and infrastructure, we see
some really phenomenal learning
and research work.
And for that, I'd like to
turn it back over to Zak Stone
to talk about research
on the frontier.
ZAK STONE: Thanks, Brennan.
We've witnessed extraordinary
breakthroughs in machine
learning research over
the past several years.
And while there are many
types of machine learning,
many of these
breakthroughs have been
concentrated at
the edges of what's
computationally possible.
And we believe that much
larger amounts of computation
are going to unlock
new discoveries
and new breakthroughs with
larger and more complex models
than researchers can practically
experiment with today.
In the photo behind
me, Wolff's daughter
represents the machine
learning research community.
The mountain represents
the breakthroughs yet
to be discovered.
And that gate is the
computational limits that
are holding researchers back.
Our goal is to break
open that gate and help
researchers climb that mountain
to unlock new discoveries.
That's why I'm thrilled that
Sundar announced the TensorFlow
Research Cloud
yesterday in order
to support open machine
learning research worldwide
and help researchers, who
currently don't have access
to enough computation,
experiment with much
larger and more complex models.
We've dedicated 1,000
of these new cloud TPUs
to accelerate open
machine learning research.
We're going to set up
an application process
to let people from
all backgrounds
and all fields of
expertise propose
projects to take advantage
of this extraordinary amount
of computing power.
This is a 180 petaflops
of compute all together.
And we can't wait to
see what new discoveries
people are going to do
with this level of compute.
What might those be?
Well, we're looking
forward to finding out.
But just to highlight one
example that Sundar also
mentioned yesterday, I'd
like to mention AutoML,
which is a family of techniques
for using machine learning
models to develop new
machine learning models.
I won't go through
the details here.
But these are just two examples
from a linguistic problem
and an image recognition
problem where
we've used the
machine learning model
to generate the architectures
that you see here
on the screen.
And the interesting thing about
it is that both of these models
look kind of
complex and organic.
They don't necessarily
look like the thing
that a mathematician might
have come up with by hand.
Now this kind of experimentation
requires immense amounts
of compute.
But fortunately, with this
step function to cloud TPUs,
and eventually to
TPU pods, we want
to shift the whole research
mindset from scarcity
to abundance so you
can start contemplating
these kinds of techniques
to search for new model
architectures and open
up new applications.
So just to be clear, we
have one underlying product
in Google Cloud, which is these
new cloud TPUs, on the Google
Compute Engine.
But we're offering the community
access to them in two ways.
For general use, we're setting
up a Cloud Alpha program that
lets businesses, start-ups,
individuals, students, people,
artists--
anyone who's interested in this
frontier of machine learning--
to sign up and try and get early
access to these limited numbers
of cloud TPUs to figure
out how to adapt them
for their applications.
But for those of
you out there who
are doing cutting edge
machine learning research,
who are extending
this frontier, we
set up the TensorFlow
Research Cloud.
And we're going to open up
this application process
to invite you in to take
advantage of these 1,000 cloud
TPUs to do things that
just aren't feasible today.
If you're interested in
either of these programs,
we encourage you to sign
up now at G.go/TPUsignup.
Optionally, tell us more
about your compute needs.
And we'll notify you as
soon as more information is
available about cloud TPUs and
the TensorFlow Research Cloud.
Now before I go, I'd
like to encourage
you to either stick around
for the next session, which
will cover TensorFlow
for non-experts
and tell you more about
the high-level APIs
that we described earlier, or
join us in the Office Hours
section for office hours.
And if you're worried, how do I
choose between the next session
and Office Hours, don't worry.
We've added a next Office
Hour after the next session
so you can do both.
Thanks again for your attention.
We're really excited about
TensorFlow and cloud TPUs.
And we look forward to speaking
with you in Office Hours.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]